quick vote who do you think the next
Dark Knight should be Batman
away from Java who's that can't be a
black guy no I think you juries Alba
should be James Bond that's fine they're
gonna give it to Tom Verlaine's to be
all Tom Hiddleston really not John Hamm
Oh Jon Hamm what are we talking about
James Bond or no Batman Oh Jake
Gyllenhaal is he already I think that's
been a reset
Oh he'd be a good one I think he'd be
good he's had to thicken up a bit yeah
he's that's just to be pretty what do
you think so must be a young Bruce Wayne
but he's also I've seen him in real life
he's not that tall they were gonna say
he's not that attractive you don't think
he is no I think he's very attractive
before the podcast before um Gio got
here um
I'm sitting there playing video games
and my girlfriend again with a bottle of
cologne mm-hmm and she goes let's stop
there I know what's happening
and she goes [ __ ] you know what he's
gonna say because he repeated back this
is not what you said this do you didn't
have cologne in your hand I did I mean
they know I sprayed there I was ready to
give a why I because they said it
smelled like bodies no and it's not
because of anyone but the fact that this
room smells like [ __ ] swear to god
sweetie I don't believe in God what she
said what does it know that white people
do you know see why people white people
you swore to God you're lying to me
right now that's it I said it smelled it
smells like farmers
hey my deals are farmers she could have
been talking about me no you hadn't been
here yet these two walk in she freaks
the [ __ ] she runs into the [ __ ]
room and she goes
who's your clone what you cloned the
wrong one I go why she goes they smell
good something that but their next price
I promise you I swear
Georgia Bryce look at me right now okay
I swear to God
she did that hey so you can take it the
way you want to take it Bryce no such
but that's you know the truth okay you
saw how she reacted Bryce I don't think
he smelled all right so you guys smell
like it's just cleaner next farmer
that's all I'm saying clean your necks
yeah you're next suck our today or what
you too what happened animals animals
but anyway um Gio you were [ __ ]
amazing thank you so much for coming
clapping Gio Antoinette everybody
[Applause]
get the [ __ ] go no I don't right now
you got anything you want to plug the
handles ah no I like you need our help
cuz you guys are really killing the game
no whatever you guys want to plug I
don't know
although follow Gio also if you want to
work out yeah it's a lot of fun
[Music]